alter wir sind im weltraum
das ist denn das für eine krake gauck
simulator übernahme ist mika und meine
damen und herren ich habe es schon lange
nicht mehr gespielt und auch schon lange
nicht mehr beim kanal hochgeladen
das beste spiel der welt bei gosee
militär geht es darum dass wir diese
ziegel sind hier ist ein typ
wir haben geld dafür bekommen dass wir
haben wir haben eine tür repariert es
geht darum dass wir diese ziele sind wir
können bisschen den brauchte keiner mehr
wir können hier ein bisschen schwachsinn
machen wir siege
das war's dann jetzt vom heutigen video
wir können hier ein bisschen rumlaufen
schwachsinn machen hier vorne kommen wir
glaube ich nicht rein
wir können sachen zerstören wir konnten
beispielsweise den luft kopfstoß
bildschirm alles klar
es ist ein total bescheuerte spiel und
ich habe davon früher unzählige parts
auf meinem kanal hochgeladen
fritz was bleibt da gefällig doch das
letzte gold simulator video auf meinem
kann alle schon über ein jahr her
deswegen haben sich einige der luca
warum hast du so lange kein goalgetter
hochgeladen die macher haben einfach
nichts verändert und da ich schon 15 20
videos zu den alten maps gemacht habe
habe ich da keinen sinn darin gesehen
dass jetzt nochmal aufzunehmen doch nun
gibt es hier eine neue methode die heiße
waste of space die gibt es tatsächlich
eigentlich schon seit zwei jahren habe
die nur irgendwie nie gefunden bei steam
wie geht's auf jeden fall darum dass wir
in diesem raumschiff hier kann nicht
verbrennen
das seitlich an den kopf gehauen
ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
ich glaube ich es abgestürzt und da
befinden wir uns wieder mehr pinkelten
der decke ja ich feiere als mega wenn
ich angepisst wäre dort habe ich
menschen ziemlich abstoßen können mit
auch sachen auf lecken das heißt während
es beispielsweise einen dollar am es
geht auf jeden fall warum wir waren in
diesem raumschiff das ding irgendwie
abgestürzt sind wir hier was ist
eigentlich mit diesem typen ja schon
wieder geld ich drücke jetzt einfach mal
auf die eins und rede mit dem omg du
bist direkt in das hauptquartier der
crowd kicker geknallt was ist traut
kicker ich habe meinen neuen sekretär
wirklich gemocht jetzt bist du hier
gelandet vielleicht kannst du uns helfen
unser ziel zu erreichen
ja das ist ein super
antwortmöglichkeiten genau so höre ich
mich an wenn ich im weltraum bin
jedenfalls wir organisieren ein
crowdfunding für eine weltraum kolonie
und brauchen unterstützung beim
geldsammeln macht das und wir reparieren
deren raumschiff und du kommst früh
genug weg ist das ein die wenn dir die
leute das geld nicht geben was du
einfach etwas zurück oder suche nach
geld kisten da sind ein paar hinter der
theke für den anfang oder mach
irgendwann ich also dass die sollen
erstmal geld clifton sein das heißt der
trümmer die habt ein bisschen geld das
hier vorne ist auch das ist einfach nur
das ist in meinem kopf los wir haben
also bei dieser map von gott simulator
wirklich eine richtige aufgabe hier
haben wir direkt ein paar kisten das
heißt kein bisschen geld einsammeln
damit wir crowdfunding der stationen
machen können ach du heilige scheiße
es sieht aus wie einer frankfurter börse
hier nur mit einer ziege mittendrin also
unser plan ist es jetzt so viel geld wie
möglich zu kriegen das heißt
da mal ein bisschen was bisher 96 dollar
hey hast du dein fuß in der wand dran
ich meine ich verdiene mein geld auch
nicht mit youtube sondern hier mit ja
oder nein
jetzt läuft er zurück kann ich nicht
dass mein neues haustier im archibald
und ich wollten auf jeden fall ein
bisschen geld holen hast du vielleicht
noch was dankeschön sehr freundlich
manchmal geht sie gut sammeln war von
ihm erhalten noch ein bisschen gemacht
ich will ein scheiß geld und ihr hier
sammelt ein bisschen cache 1 dann von
ihm hier vorne auch noch also das ist
glaube ich erst mal jetzt unsere erste
mission die finanzierung finanziert ach
du heilige scheiße das hab ich kann ich
daher oh hallo alle frauen fallen von
mir auf die knie
die hier vorne sollen auch noch ein
bisschen geld geben also unsere aufgabe
ist es jetzt falcao lateral schaden wenn
das fordert wäre würde ich mir jetzt
halt irgendwie noch treppen hoch bauen
sodass nicht vielleicht noch ein
bisschen höher gehen kann aber ich würde
sagen ich habe erst mal ein bisschen
gelder ein
wir haben eher 4182 was macht sie denn
dafür ein aufstand alter und warum liegt
da so unfassbar viel scheiße in diesem
silo ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt
erst mal weiterhin den nächsten raum
denn den haben wir jetzt gerade
freigeschaltet hallo
geld ist auch geld für mich mitnehmen ja
mitnimmt einstufe naja diese spieler
nicht so bescheuert nämlich sich halt
somit haben wir den vorteil hat ein
bürger kann ich dem ich hab ja so
reagiere ich auch mal wenn ich bürger
sehr so sieht das ganze hier unten aus
also ich glaube das sind wirklich
irgendwelche fische die darum schwimmen
schon mal was ist denn los mit dieser
ziele habe ich mit dir hier irgendwie
reden aber das sieht ein bisschen falsch
aus gerade also hier geht es zu diesem
kraut kicker lobby ding wo wir grad
waren und dann haben wir hier einmal die
landeplattform und die kolonie die
landeplattform habe ich noch nicht
freigeschaltet allerdings die kolonie
das heißt wir gehen jetzt mal hierhin
leute erstmal das ist ja komplett anders
als die bisherigen dlcs sage ich mal
oder diese anderen maps und man wirklich
keine einzige aufgabe hatte hier muss
ich jetzt mal wirklich geld einsammeln
um ein raumschiff zu reparieren et
cetera pp also wenn ihr bock habt dass
sich daraus auch jetzt hat sich die
ziege glaube ich wehgetan bock habt dass
sich wieder öfter golfsimulator
hochladen dann lass auf jeden fall mal
ein leichter und bei 40.000 likes
eine hohe zahl werde ich dann nächste
woche neuen part hier von luca in der
raumstation hochladen allerdings ist
unsere jetzige aufgabe erst mal hin
ich habe ich habe einen helm auf jetzt
tatsächlich jeder seinen helm auf der
hier hat auf jeden fall erstmal sogar
noch ein bisschen geld was ich mir
gönnen kann alcoa
[Applaus]
88 leute die sind im weltraum ersetzen
das für eine kranke neue map hier vorne
liegen irgendwie zwei leute und haben
darauf kann ich nicht so wie sie weg
geflogen ist ich wollte jetzt hier
wirklich nicht euer date irgendwie
zerstören ich meine ich kann mich auch
hier zu bringen ja tut mir leid für euch
wenn ich den bürgern noch hätte würde
ich den euch geben ich kann hier einfach
wieder zurück dahin lenken zurück dahin
lenken gehört sich auch ein bisschen
falsch an lecken hjk
es ist ein mensch man kann mal aufhören
die erde dazu essen so ich bring dich
hier schön zu deinem kumpel liegen
hallo ich will euch nur wieder
zusammenbringen so gehen wir dahin soll
sehr schön dass die kinder war schnell
zur sache ihr euch auf jeden fall noch
ganz viel auch noch eure manzi gehört
aber auf jetzt die kerze mitzunehmen
euch doch ganz viel spaß bei eurem date
da vorne ich erkunde das ganze mal so
ein bisschen was er tue
das ist dass halo sind das
kopfstoß shani tatorts
hey nasa wenn ihr neuen astronauten
braucht nehmen mich ich kenne schon alle
begriffe genau ich weiß nicht was ich
mit dem steht hier machen soll aber
anscheinend ist er ja noch ein bisschen
mehr von diesem krams mit drin
wahrscheinlich brauche ich die für die
nächste crash oder irgendwie sowas oder
musste irgendwo hinbringen
ich nehme den erstmal mit den andern
kann ich nicht direkt mitnehmen weil wir
so schön 10 zerschlagen in franken ging
wo hier muss doch mit dem ding hier also
leute das ist echt eine riesige web
allein hier raus und es gibt ja auch
noch die test kann man es gibt noch
verschiedene weitere sachen als ich
hoffe dass sie die like anzahl schafft
und dass ich hey ziege ich gestolpert
aber ich hoffe dass sie die landschaft
hoch
was ist denn das ist denn deine mission
hier einfach im bett vor mir weglaufen
nach dem ja gar keinen sinn mit beinahe
alter was passiert wenn ich jetzt so
mache ja nicht gleich dem stoos geben
xamax ist verschwunden also leute ich
weiß im wahrsten sinne des wortes nicht
was hier abgeht
hier vorne geht es auch noch irgendwo
lang also es gibt die die met ist
wirklich glaube ich bisher mit die
größte möglichkeit mich jetzt nur noch
ein bisschen geld auch alter ach du
scheiße tut mir leid da achter der leute
schon wieder ich weiß gar nicht was ich
jetzt hier irgendwie draußen machen soll
ich kommt das jetzt hier freischalten im
nächstes ziel gründung eines raumflug
museums ich will allerdings sagen dass
wir uns um die gründung eines raumflug
museums im nächsten teil nächste woche
bei gott simulator mit luc ackermann
werden falls ihr jetzt 1000 leid schafft
schreibt man die kommentare ob er
überhaupt bock auf wieder geld auf
meinem kanal hat ja auch sein dass die
meisten hier jetzt nach zehn millionen
parts luca spielt vielleicht noch dumme
scheiße gar keinen bock mehr darauf
haben ob drauf habt ich habe auf jeden
fall wenn der neue web tv
[Musik]